Україні за останні роки вдалося
створити нову армію, запевняє Петро Порошенко.
За два тижні до виборів президент розповів
про свої досягнення в інтерв’ю українським журналістам.
- Україна не просто відродила,
Україна створила нову армію.
DW перевірила:
Стара техніка, брак бронежилетів
та військової форми - таким було українське військо
на початку російської агресії. За останні п’ять років
Збройні Сили України зміцніли і оновили склад.
Якщо на початку 2014-го в активі збройних сил було
близько 150 тисяч військових, то нині на захисті країни -
близько 250 тисяч бійців.
Іще 160 тисяч - оперативний резерв.
Утім, натепер оновилася здебільшого низова і
середня ланка управління, зазначають військові аналітики.
Водночас серед вищих чинів оновлення відбулося
не більше, ніж на третину, решта - старі кадри.
Вони, за словами оглядачів, не хочуть втрачати
робочі місця і статус, і тому нерідко чинять опір
реформам, що загалом гальмує розвиток армії.
Іще одна негативна тенденція: контрактники
активно звільняються з українського війська.
За останні два роки кількість тих, хто йде з армії,
за даними Генштабу, зросла в 10 разів порівняно
з 2016-м роком. Такий стан справ військові
чиновники пояснюють низькою зарплатнею,
браком житла, а також застарілим озброєнням.
Водночас самі контрактники публічно скаржаться
на свавілля командирів, радянські підходи
в управлінні та навіть побої й побори.
Радянським в українському війську поки що
лишається й левова частка озброєння.
За оцінками експертів, це близько 80-90% техніки,
хоча її модернізують на українських підприємствах
- ремонтують двигуни, встановлюють нові види озброєння.
Україна також приймає на озброєння нові зразки.
Це, приміром, протитанковий комплекс "Стугна",
а також ракетний комплекс "Вільха".
Загалом, за даними Генштабу, з 2014 року
відремонтовано та оновлено половину озброєння та військової техніки.
Якщо ж говорити про флот, то за рівнем розвитку
Військово-Морських Сил у рейтингу Global Firepower
Україна - на 75 місці серед 136 армій світу:
між Гватемалою та Демократичною Республікою Конго.
Після анексії Криму Росією українські
військово-морські сили втратили понад 80% активів.
Ці втрати і призвели до послаблення позицій
української армії у рейтингу. Адже попри
бойовий досвід і краще забезпечення, нині
Збройні сили України посідають 29 місце, тоді як
п’ять років тому були на 21-му.
Служити в армії стало престижніше, адже
з початком російської агресії
імідж українського війська значно покращився.
Нині армія разом із волонтерськими організаціями
та церквою - серед тих, кому українці довіряють найбільше.
Серед покращень в українському війську
за останні роки нерідко називають і оновлену
систему харчування в армії. Після відмови
Міноборони від послуг фірм-аутсорсерів, які колись
готували їжу для військових, частини почали самі
наймати кухарів і закуповувати продукти,
тож до меню військових почали додавати екзотичні фрукти, десерти та йогурти.
Щоправда, на нову систему харчування перейшли
лише 40% військових частин - 70 із близько 200.
Повний перехід заплановано на цей рік, проте
військові аналітики наголошують: це буде непросто.
Із початком бойових дій на Сході збільшилася
й кількість тренувань українських військових.
І якщо у 2013-2014 роках не було жодного
бригадного тактичного навчання,
зараз - більше 30 на рік.
Теза "нова армія" була традиційною в арсеналі
Петра Порошенка протягом усього його
президентства і не дивно, що він використав її
у передвиборний період. Проте військові аналітики
наголошують: говорити про повністю нову
українську армію нині зарано. Через бойові дії
на Сході України військові отримали величезний
бойовий досвід, Збройні Сили змінюються та
міцнішають, їхній імідж значно покращився.
Разом із тим, в українській армії досі лишається
здебільшого зброя радянських часів і старі підходи
до організації служби, тож нині йдеться радше
про відчутне оновлення українського війська,
яке перебуває на шляху реформ, аніж про нову армію.